em 2011 ao invés de crédito em janeiro
de 2012 está muito pra variar ser muito
rápido em janeiro de 2012 é maria josé
foi ao encontro e vai nu
preciso me ajude a concretizar um
objectivo e vamos embora pra variar é
sempre essa resposta
eu nunca disse que não e então qual é o
objetivo do potente criança de maratona
o espetáculo quando as mesmas já fizeram
até hoje muito bom qual foi o máximo que
logo que conseguiu correr até os dias de
hoje com a quilômetros e quem pulava e
eu começo fantástico 10% da maratona são
fait restam os 90% e assim durante e
neste caso todos os desafios que se
colocam só são desafios se os mesmos
foram parceiras haiti e mais parceiros
sites só ser concretizadas e sim um ano
e quatro meses depois de muitos
quilômetros pernas muitos
engarrafamentos muita água e não chora
porque tava sempre há ainda o poder não
aguenta e não chora porque é isso nosso
objetivo está há um ano e quatro metros
de distância e temos 90% para
concretizar a ida em abril em abril de
fizemos a nossa primeira maratona e foi
o barcelona
armando também com a nossa presença dos
três
a paixão pelo desporto é algo que vai
desde sempre desde o começo ao fim da
canção foi só por acaso é e todos estão
em volta de mim alguns que estão aqui eu
tenho segundo tempo aos pratica
atividade física nomeadamente nas casas
a corrida e é o meu desígnio é mesmo
isto é motivar os alunos motivar todos
os amigos e vocês no final da prova
também vão ficar motivado para tal
estava na hora de investir estava na
hora de falar em tal muito cheio e então
estava na hora de a gente estava na hora
onde gostou mas deve ter e colocar
a cidade que a vaia é correr é mexer é
criar um estilo de vida saudável aos 15
o positivo e assim a origem é a origem
de tudo isto surge a 29 de agosto de
criamos a ver na trama seu e um grupo
que acompanha todos os xavantes
ininterruptamente desde desde esta data
29 de agosto
pensava eu vai criar isso convidei o
teste do freio das pessoas que era para
andar aqui ó a tocar sozinho já estava
garantido iria de excesso pelo menos 10
igual foi bastante quando chegamos ao
local marcado e por serão corretas
a intenção do verso fantástico não
apareceram 200 pessoas
isto mostra e só mostra que se estava a
passar e também gostava muito mas
faltava impulso que faltava é que um
clique para eles virem e pelo ser em
casa e sempre nos fala das suas zonas de
conforto e assim foram 140 mais 140
eventos depois que estamos nos dias 12
esta hora estamos a começar os
preparativos e estou aqui mas de lá
estar mas tenho um grupo fantástico que
me ajuda neste neste percurso e 1.300 km
já procuramos todos os sábados mil e 300
carros por quem não faltou cerca de mil
desenhos 1.250 que novos documentos
chegava à conclusão criarmos uma tribo
chegamos à conclusão que criar uma
comunidade e comunidade esta comunidade
é esta que cria um pouco mais e por que
não criar algo um pouco mais organizado
além de estava na travessa e assim e
assim até os dias de hoje nós lançamos é
é legal isso é gênio é sempre avaí o
primeiro evento é sempre em aveiro onde
tivemos 14 anos até os dias de hoje
fizemos duas são sorvetes em aveiro e em
terceiro está agendada para dia 3 de
dezembro
fizemos a primeira meia maratona da
bahia foi há um mês atrás e lançarmos a
primeira sanção é primeiro céu ferran
foi a semana passada
que algum estoque procurar outras
estréias sempre a mesma coisa está sendo
trazido aqui para quem tem carro
esqueça o carro saiu de casa e vai dar
poder às pessoas porque ela foi um cinto
deste evento também por todo o turismo e
acima de tudo queremos que a vale seja
ativa e para isso todos nós estamos
cobrar neste sítio mais de 23 anos mais
de 23 mil pessoas participaram nestes
eventos que falei anteriormente mais
três mineiros foram goleados e
distribuídos por essas seções locais e
nacionais
mas todos nós todos nós criamos um pouco
mais ainda e norte a sul do país nota
superior dos correios maratonas 10
quilômetros são silvestre e não só
ganhava todos estes looks compostos
podem estar agora apoiará correm conosco
e já fizeram grandes desafios
já fiz te tornas e aquela marido dela
naquela inicial já fez site só fazer
quatro quilômetros e ela já fez seis
batalhões comigo
vejo nisso madrid admite que não é
mítica maratona de nova york filha e
esta última em viena de áustria temos
agora em setembro para mim e enfrento
tóquio pois quem quiser não estarão tão
à vontade começa já a pensar no final
lançaremos repto e agora estão vocês
todas é uma maratona chamam o que eu até
gostava
os 42.195 metros
acho que é muito não é está ok mas de
todos que aqui estão e é segundo com 50
mas todos estão aqui à frente só está ao
alcance de todos basta ter a disciplina
dos três meses e esse tipo não é só na
maratona
o desporto é também na vossa vida
profissional dedicação determinação e
disciplina
esses três ingredientes com os gatos
levam somente uma única palavra o
sucesso
por isso tem que estar focados tem que
ser aquilo que vocês querem fazer
acreditar e partir do momento em que
tudo está com os dava aquela visita só
dae teve muita sorte diz que são só
pessoas vai aparecer propostas vão ter
que procurar e isto é a realidade ea
maratona
agora todos querem correr com uma amiga
e tal como ele usa topete dizia mas
quiseram usar a vossa vida como uma
maratona e testemunhal todos vós hábitos
de vida vão ter que alterar um bocadinho
sou um quilinho não precisar eu vou
estar na minha vida tem que ter muito
tempo com ele não tá aí acredita que não
tem é mais fácil do que a nossa
expressão e aqui está o problema ea
moratória propriamente então maratona
começa o novo ninho principalmente
aqueles que vão iniciar é essa distância
é que vai estar com meu sogro que os
primeiros momentos da maratona os
primeiros 21 quilômetros
surgem naturalmente pública apoiada por
lá está com a gente os jogos passaram
bastante e agora é começar a maratona é
o psicológico vai trabalhar porque as
pernas onda cabeça manda e esse vídeo
que logo vem a seguir em vão ser aqueles
do doloroso e pato chegou ea nossa
cabeça começa a ser para olha aquele
desgraçado que a embraer já que eu
estava para sair da crise pioraram ea
nosso méxico está a ter uma quebra tinha
salas 30 e 33 quilômetros e vai do homem
da marreta da manhã é mesmo tal e qual a
marreta e nós caímos que começamos ali
calma e agora tenho mais desde os que
achou frente mas a nossa mente tem que
ser superior e aí é ia com o espírito
maratonista o nosso foco está nos 42 195
e aí que eu tenho que chegar mas aos 35
anos atualmente nem que seja um pouco a
dar um chega aos 40
- já estão ali os 42 2km nos falta já
não há dores não há nada fantástico
chegando às correntezas que novos mas
ainda faltam os 195 metros surgir e de
segmentos glória é ao fantástico ela que
todo o público está e volta a levantar
os braços e vai vai neste momento mas
nós terminamos levantando os braços e
surdos baianos neste momento somos
maiores lá ninguém manhãs e começamos a
pensar na próxima vez causamos é um
passo em frente em ministérios não é não
minhas pernas estão duas tábuas
autênticas e espero é que não haja
escadas que o bairro se houver aí é
assim que antes elas iam demonstrarem
que faria 12 horas
depois do douro sabemos que estudos
mostram que para evitar que falar mais
três anos
estudos mostram que atividade física
estilo saudável tem uma diminuição da
pressão arterial o bugre da necessidade
era óssea podem sofrer do fato esforço
não há stress mas já estou pronto não
vão sofrer
administrando isso que se quer ver quem
posou na melhoria da autoestima um livre
do estresse e humor
o humor vai ser fantástico não vou ficar
chateado com nada esqueçam isso
sendo assim deixou muito nossas amigas
liberta-nos esta sexta e poderia estar
aqui falar muito mais aspectos e diz eu
corro maratonas
alguns aqui também para o outro corre
mesmo para todas os outros só 10
quilômetros eo totalmente caminhão mas
acho que todos todos concordam com a
idéia que o estilo de vida saudável é
fundamental para nós é fundamental para
nossos dias e agora quem daqui embora
comigo podem levantar quem é daqui que
embora comigo só na não vai cair na não
possa não aqui dentro da área desculpem
lá boba melhora mas ainda temos aqui um
logo muito vai e ok
o desafio nas ruas agora podem acertar a
questão muito pensado foi duro e 195
metros
o desafio dos lances e agora é tudo
estou aqui amanhã às 17 horas na fonte
nova e um tal como fez a 29 de agosto de
2013 e 1 vou estar a certeza gosta mais
dez comícios
eu não vou te ensinar a ninguém desta
vez e agora quero que todos todos sem
exceção as taxas vão fazer o maior
evento do governo através do domingo
obrigado a todos e pela suspensão